[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce tout
premier cyan par les spores de l'année à
2020 et je vous promets un très grand
cru cette année il y aura comme toujours
des analyses des débats et des duels
entre nos chroniqueurs ils sont quatre
autour de cette table aujourd'hui pour
m'accompagner présentation on commence à
ma droite
il est de retour dans cette émission il
est vice président de la fédération
française de cyclisme y fait également
partie du club de vélizy 78 qui l'a déjà
fait paris pékin à vélo est passé plus
de 24 heures sur un vélo pour une bonne
cause pour le téléthon au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
jean michel richefort nous fait le
plaisir de venir dans cette émission
bonjour quand allez-vous jean-michel
parfait parfait on commence 2020 en
super forme
qu'est ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter
justement pour 2020 la santé beaucoup
beaucoup de vélo il y en aura dans les
yvelines
il y en aura au vélodrome nationale un
nouveau record en vue ou pas ah non non
24 heures vélo c'est fini c'est terminé
dont il faut laisser la place aux jeunes
on passe de l'autre côté un musique
c'est un petit nouveau dans l'équipe
aujourd'hui fêtera sa deuxième
titularisation il est passionné de
football et notamment fans du club de
saint-etienne il fait également du
handball fauteuil à montigny le
bretonneux était fan de visée sera avec
nous pendant une heure pour ce talk
stéphane comment allez vous moi ça va
très très bien que tout retourner très
rapidement
oui oui monsieur j'étais un peu vous
avez parlé de saint-etienne et comme je
suis en guerre avec eux non c'est pas
saint-etienne en ce moment n'ont aucun
droit pour certains sinon non non non
non là je suis en froid il n'ya pas les
résultats y à rien alors on vous
surnomme méchant handicapés louis
méchant je sais pas pourquoi je suis
d'une gentillesse extrême jeu j'essaye
de faire plaisir à tout le monde et puis
voilà dans la question qu'est ce qu'on
peut vous souhaiter cette année 2 parce
que là pendant quinze jours j'ai bord
est descendu hicham entendant devrait
jamais quitter montauban et plus jamais
ça plus jamais ça que jamais ça je vais
être heureux dans la vie
je vais être heureux j'en peux plus
d'émoi pitié parce que l'autre côté
musique qui nous vient tout droit de
versailles il est venu avec sa bonne
humeur son franc parler ses anecdotes
vous allez passer un excellent moment
avec lui j'en suis sûr pierre chevallier
du rugby-club de versailles est avec
nous bonjour unum soir
comment allez vous ça va très bien en
pleine forme pour démarrer cette balade
est justement de la résolution les
bonnes résolutions c'est le sport diyala
ont j'en fais déjà chaque année donc
donc ça ça va peut-être une petite
échéance de course à pied a fixé donc se
préparer et puis aller au bout au bout
de l'événement des résultats saint
pierre dans cette émission pour ça et
puis une forte qui se maintient en
termine
de l'autre côté à musique c'est une
légende l'un des piliers de cette
émission il fait partie de la famille si
on parlait ce sport en 2020 il l'a
promis il sera très sage genlis
ex-entraîneur de plaisir est avec nous
bonjour jean moulin aujourd'hui qu'elle
jouera tous depuis nombre d'années à
tout le monde donc une année faste et
sous le signe de la sagesse s'agit
toujours toujours toujours vous avez
d'autres résolutions vous pas du tout
les bords de sarthe est d'abord la sadc
le plus grand trésor kobus avoir très
bonne santé à tous non plus voilà alors
avant de passer au titre du thème de
l'émission commence par une information
insolite qui concerne le paris
saint-germain le club de la capitale
dans son jus de poire artisanale si vous
m'avez bien entendu les fruits seront
100% yvelinois ils proviendront de deux
vergers installé sur le futur centre
d'entraînement du psg installe à poissy
au total 2800 poirier de cette variété
différente sont implantés sur 2 5 ha
mille bouteilles seront servis jusqu'à
la fin de la saison spectateurs des
espaces hospitalité au parc des princes
la question sur cette thématique est ce
que c'est une bonne idée si vous votez
oui
pour pierre oui pour jean-michel oui
pour stéphane et oui pour jean également
gens vous a été le
plus lent à dégainer mais c'est quoi
l'intérêt c'est quoi intéresser poids
pour payer ma paix n'ont qu'un pas non
pas parvenue du jus de poire pour payer
ma paie pas souvent l'apport williams
nom du jus de poire je suis de pouvoir
de pression de poissy siècle jus de
poire de poissy c'est nickel bon c'est
bien parce que ça me +7 plus du
marketing c'est autre chose ça sort de
l'ordinaire on va dire et c'est lionel
artisans et artisanes à piau et il
n'aime pas quelqu'un qui font du jus de
poire ou du jus de pommes jus de fruits
artisanale hélas beaucoup c'est pas le
psg certes c'est une première pour un
club de football
mais non justement voilà c'est ce que je
dis c'est c'est particulier donc oui
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
coûter pour une chaleur fit pas la saint
michel
moi je trouve que c'est une excellente
idée et ça va permettre de promouvoir
donc les bergers de poissy les
propriétaires qui font cette ces genres
de deux cultures c'est la pub pour les
yvelines c'est de la pub pour les
récoltants et puis pour le port le fruit
pour le fruit voilà maintenant j'en
avais jamais entendu parler autant de
poires en ce moment il n'y a que des
bonnes poires au psg stéphane moi j'ai
encore l'image de ce que je dis pas ce
que je veux dire c'est que bon il
utilise le verger qui avait au camp
d'entraînement au futur camp
d'entraînement où il était déjà là on se
les jeunes qui veulent le rentabiliser
se diversifier c'est très bien pour leur
image après heureusement que ce n'était
pas une plantation de cannabis
c'est en tout cas c'est un chevalier
avancée des gestes éco-responsables je
trouve que c'est plutôt bien qu'une
équipe aussi exposé médiatiquement que
le psg se fasse sa petite pierre à
l'édifice sur le côté éco responsable
après les petites pelles et tiff le fond
les font les grandes les petits les
petites rivières font les grands fleuves
pardon donc cesser c'est une bonne chose
c'est original c'est un positionnement
est ce que ce sera déterminant dans la
dans le la poursuite de la bonne image
du psg et d'éco responsabilité sans
doute un petit peu de toute façon ça
peut pas faire de mal aux principes
c'est donne c'est au-delà d'être
original c'est local donc c'est que
c'est une très bonne idée
certes marc été mais c'est une très
bonne idée il m'a tendu vendre leurs
parts aux seynois tout à fait petit tour
de table qui seraient prêts à l'acheter
si on veut juste avril vallier mais
c'est juste à côté un comédien mais
voilà vous avez peut-être financer le
bape et un du coup un peu car une partie
comme partie sa trempe ont droit alors
nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler de boxe
ahmed el moussaoui le verrou a terminé
2019 par une victoire espère maintenant
combattre pour un championnat du monde
en 2020 font également un coup de
projecteur sur le à paris-nice la course
cycliste passera par les yvelines pour
la onzième année consécutive
mais avant de développer ces thèmes on
va parler à football
[Musique]
un stade bien garni pour une affiche
historique 2000 supporters ont fait le
déplacement pour voir ce 32e de finale
de coupe de france entre versailles et
granville c'était le 4 janvier dernier
les versailles qui évolue en nationale 3
n'avait plus atteint ce stade de la
compétition depuis 2011 malgré leurs
divisions d'écart les versailles et
marquent en premier sur penalty mais se
font rejoindre quelques minutes plus
tard le score à la mi temps un partout
granville marquera un second but en
seconde période malgré quelques actions
en fin de match et les encouragements
des supporters versailles ne reviendra
pas et se fait sortir de la coupe de
france sur le score de 2 1 ils ont
montré un petit peu plus d'expérience
que nous là sur ce mot sur ce genre de
match qui sont quand même important donc
j'ai tiré un peu plus d'expérience après
je pense pas qu'on avait quelque chose à
leur envier que ce soit techniquement ou
physiquement
il fait une ou deux erreurs sans ciment
qui nous ont coûté des buts on était
puni froidement
mais voilà c'est la vérité du 32e de
finale de coupe de france de ce niveau
là et là dessus il faut il faut
apprendre
du côté des supporters les sentiments
sont partagés on est quand même content
de la prestation des joueurs mais on
aurait pu gagner faire beaucoup mieux
mais c'est pas grave on a vécu quand
même un bon match quand on regarde le
contenu ça laisse ça laisse des regrets
parce que c'est dommage voilà maintenant
il ya des faits de jeu et perdre
mieux vaut continuer je pense qu'ils
vont gagner le championnat de n3 ce sera
la consommation de cette année la
question sur ce thème le club de
versailles sort-il par la petite porte
oui ou non non oui pour stephen oui pour
gens lui ont fait un petit duel entre
stéphane et pierre stéphane vous
commencez donc histoire petite porte
pour vous oui oui parce qu'ils avaient
les moyens de passer encore un tour
supplémentaire
ce grand ville et en milieu de tableau
la division au-dessus certes mais
versailles leader de son championnat
donc je pense que les deux ça c'est
qu'ils vont un peu je pense qu'il y
avait moyen de faire quelque chose et
ramener un grand club au tour suivant à
versailles
là je pense qu'ils ont raté une bonne
occasion un techo para ils ont vraiment
raté le coche donc il ya plus que c'est
versailles web le tour suivant en colère
on en parle un grand ville aurait mis
par m il peut y avoir des réserves louis
mais les petites portes non dans la
mesure où c'est un 32e de finale de
coupe de france on sait que les tableaux
de coupe de france on sont extrêmement
exigeants
c'est une aventure qui chaque année
consacre les petits poucet est qui qui a
son lot de surprises à chaque fois ci la
régie ressort les cassettes vhs de des
dernières émissions je pense qu'on avait
été presque presque parfait sur les
prévisions à un détail près celle celui
de la victoire
puisqu'on avait on avait imaginé que si
versailles pas celle autour de granville
on pouvait on pouvait espérer un gros
derrière c'est marseille qui ce qui se
pointe qui se pointent derrière
après c'est une courte défaite elle est
regrettable dans le scénario parce que
parce que c'est un c'est un but en
deuxième mi temps et c'est effectivement
peut-être comparable en terme de niveau
mais je mets le coup de chapeau et déjà
attiré à versailles pour pour s'être
hissés jusqu'aux trente deuxièmes de
finale
alors oui des will des regrets encore
une fois mais mais mais une porte qui
était moyenne
elle sort par la moyenne portes et avec
un avec son lot de son lot de regrets
ça relève pas leurs mérites mais je
pense que vraiment il y avait moyen de
passer ce tour-là jean michel richefort
qui vous a convaincu alors vous étiez
plus de l'avis de stéphane wissant par
la petite porte
ils sortent quand même par la petite
porte en fait pas vraiment pas par la
petite porte mais il ya énormément de
regrets et je crois que c'est un manque
de conviction également parce que ça
c'est la magie de la de la coupe de
france même si on est dans une division
inférieure
bon tout est possible moi j'ai eu la
chance d'assister
au match om trélissac à limoges et
trélissac qui se sont battus ils se sont
battus jusqu'au bout ils ont tenu tête à
l'om et ils ont vraiment failli passer
eux ils sont sortis par la grande porte
alors qu'il y avait cinq divisions des
gays il ya cinq divisions d'écart et
faut voir mais jusqu'au bout là
lorsqu'on joue ce genre de match bon
mais c'est des matches couperets mais il
faut avoir beaucoup plus de conviction
ni 3 quand c'est pas un match est bon
d'accord il joue il ya des regrets mais
existent manque encore à condensation 1
but à 0 et oui quand on mène 1 but à 0
mais on se voit là après sur des erreurs
il ya toujours des excès oui on a fait
des erreurs effectivement mais il
pouvait passer il pouvait passer haut la
main je pense
voilà c'est grand vide est une équipe de
coupe
dire que chaque année chaque année ils
sont bien présents donc c'est aussi un
sacré client
à ce stade là de la compétition et
deuxièmement c c'est une porte que je
trouve moyenne ou grande malgré tout sur
l' influence qui avait à bord on est
autour du autour du stade avec une avec
une belle fête du football à versailles
des microbes présents lieu l'an passé
quand
quand versailles avait reçu l'an ce
genre est ce qu'ils ont fait leur preuve
de suffisance c'est versailles
alors moi je ne pense pas parce que y
est c'est une équipe qui joue les deux
tableaux ils jouent leur jeu là ils sont
leaders de milliers de candidats déjà
sur l'a9 entre donc à ce titre là il est
difficile de courir plusieurs lièvres à
la fois et comme disait jean michel
avoir pu naître la niaque la niaque
rennaise mais sauf qu'il ne mise pas
leur saison sur la coupe de france alors
que trélissac
peut-être que trélissac l'avait vraiment
grave ça non maîtrisée il s'était très
lisse ac l'om qui s'était déchiré sauf
que sauf que là la priorité du club de
versailles n'est peut-être pas la coupe
de france la coupe de france c'est
peut-être la cerise sur le gâteau est la
priorité c'est le championnat et c'est
finir premier et pouvoir a essayé
d'accéder au niveau supérieur
donc c'est pour ça que moi je dis non
ici pour moi ils sortent pas par la
petite porte parce que mais ils font
déjà une belle performance
il faut une belle saison en nationale 3
et que encore une fois je répète pour
moi c'était la cerise sur le gâteau et
c'est pas du tout en 32e de finale de
coupe de france
il faut déjà y arriver avec toujours des
regrets mais quand on perd surtout 2
il aurait pris 5 0 on a dit bon bah oui
ils avaient la possibilité si en cas de
victoire d'égaler le meilleur parcours
de l'histoire du club
c'était un 16e de finale en 1948 il
avait perdu 4 à 1 face à gueugnon
à l'époque si gagner ce match-là il
égalait le record du club
mais l'histoire est faite pour être
chargé donc
c'est pas cette année ce sera l'année
prochaine à l'om
au tour suivant il aurait pu affronter
l'om serre-chevalier c'est le fameux le
fameux gros qu'on espérait 6,6
versailles passé il ya déjà fait lance
fait la saison précédente
8e tour avait perdu 4 accueilli oui
c'est tout c'est toute la magie de la
coupe de france qu'on a qu'on a rappelé
c'est justement pour permettre à des
assez petit poucet à ses équipes de plus
petits niveaux de se frotter à des
équipes de ligue 1 ou de ligue 2 et puis
de créer la surprise c'est ça qui est
fantastique sur la coupe de france et
que sur un match les cartes sont
rebattues il peut y avoir cinq divisions
d'écart ou uniquement une division
d'écart et le et après c'est celui qui a
le plus envie qui sait pas forcément le
meilleur sur le papier mais ce celui qui
a le plus envie qui passe
stéphane l'om ils ont rappelé affronter
l'om au tour suivant
on saura plus une belle fête du football
quand on résultat bon ben je suis pas
sûr pour versailles mais ça aurait pu
être intéressant pour la ville
médiatiquement cet homme aurait pu faire
d'une autre histoire que granville
voilà puis même pour pour leur attaquant
à quoi sous à coup sûr je n'arrive
jamais à dire son nom
vianne aquasure vue à l'acquis qui sur
le viseur de pas mal de clubs de l1 l2
et même anglais ça aurait pu permettre
pour lui encore de se faire voir et
pourquoi pas de de tenter un truc
l'année prochaine là il va un peu
retombée pas dans l'oubli mais dans la
voilà dans la n3 je pense que voilà
maintenant c'est une occasion gâchée
pour lui je trouve verser en tout cas
c'est bien repris les versets ils ont
emporté 3 buts à 0 à domicile contre
l'équipe ii du paris saint-germain juste
après leur élimination de la coupe de
france les versets ils sont toujours
premiers du championnat de nationale 3
on l'a dit a précédemment en forme on
l'oubliera pas eu de boxe à présent
c'était là à des combats à français de
cette fin d'année au palais des sports
de marseille le verrez roi ahmed el
moussaoui s'est imposé aux points par
décision unanime face aux russes vague
in acte abrasion ce combat international
a compté dans la catégorie des poids
welters moins de 69 kg ahmed el
moussaoui affiche désormais un bilan de
32 vie
un nul et trois défaites ils voudraient
maintenant un boxer pour un titre on
écoute tout est possible après le qui
est possible c'est en fait c'est qui est
derrière et après avoir une chance
mondiale tête à la fin d'année mais fin
d'année 2010 vers nation ouais on m'a
déjà proposé un champion mais bon après
faut voir le contexte sexta mais tout
est possible bien sûr je vous rappelle
qu ahmed el moussaoui a presque 30 ans
et qu'il affiche un bilan de 32
victoires trois défaites et un nul
la question sur ce thème 2020 l'année où
jamais pour ahmed el moussaoui
oui ou non on rappelle son âge presque
30 ans oui vous êtes unanime
jean-michel willy mériterait
effectivement connaître la contre la
consécration participer à un championnat
du monde c'est le rêve de tout boxeur
c'est vraiment le grave est dans un
sport hyper hyper difficile
donc moi je pense que c'est cette année
ou jamais et mon il arrive quand même
maturité
je pense qu'il en a les moyens et bon il
faut lui souhaiter de combattre pour un
titre mondial en 2020 genre ou qu'ils
adoraient la boxe oui je me souviens que
j'aime bien j'aime j'aime bien la boxe
tout à fait mais jen mois pour lui
effectivement ils arrivent à avoir
erreur 30 ans on connaît la difficulté
le parcours qu'il faut qu'il faut faire
pour accéder à avoir un combat pour un
titre championne du monde donc il est
certain que si si si s'il n'a pas faim
s'il n'a pas déjà la possibilité en 2020
et surtout si là puisqu'il espère la
voir parce qu'il aura la possibilité
ce sera pour moi après la une des
dernières chances pour lui d'avoir un
titre mondial
parce qu'après encore une fois le temps
de refaire un petit peu ces classes
entre guillemets pour pouvoir après le
lui permettre qu'on leur propose un
championnat du monde
ben là je serai sera là il commet il
commencera bon après on a vu comme des
boxeurs à 34 35 ans qui était encore au
niveau
mais on sait bien aussi que je pense que
les 9 30 c'est l'âge mûr et je crois que
c'est vraiment pour lui c'est le moment
quoi parce qu'un bus il a beau palmarès
et qu'il est qu'il est pour moi au
sommet de sa de 2 de sa forme et
et je crois que pour lui ce serait ce
sera l'aboutissement de sa carrière
stéphane vous êtes d'accord avec jean
tout à fait d'accord tout à fait
d'accord tout à fait même temps jean est
un amateur de boxe et hop il fait très
peur pierre chevalier
je suis partagé entre le entre deux
choses entre la l'expérience d'un boxeur
qui se rapproche et qui va dépasser la
trentaine et celle de l'exigence
physique dont parlait indirectement gens
sur les préparations de combat sur les
sur justement les le parcours du
combattant qu'il faut qu'il faut
traverser pour pouvoir s'aligner sur un
sur une réunion de champion du lot de
championnat du monde donc là je je
dirais qu'à une trentaine d'années
malgré tout sur deux sur un arbre comme
celui de la boxe c'est peut-être jose de
croire que c'est l'expérience qui peut
qui peut jouer donc c'est là où il est
au sommet de son art au sommet de sa
forme et que etc c'est l'année où jamais
ce qu'il faut lui souhaiter
sans l'enterrait totalement si jamais
2020 ne se passe pas comme il leur a
souhaité justement l'expérience c'est ce
qu'il n'avait pas eu sur son précédent
combat il avait eu quasiment une chance
de championnat du monde il fallait
qu'ils battent en nouvelle zélande
jeff horn c'était en 2015 finalement il
avait perdu ce titre intercontinental
des poids welters il avait perdu aux
points mais il était à blesser à ce
moment là au biceps il n'avait pas
déclaré sa blessure pour pouvoir
combattre pour avoir un championnat du
monde derrière
finalement il aura peut-être cette
expérience là c'est impressionnant cela
en plus et surtout un mental et 10 et
parce que se combattre combattre
affaiblit sa marque et sa forge en boxe
une défaite ça pardonne pas on peut le
dire jean vous le disiez tout à l'heure
il faut refaire ses classes après mais
oui surtout à ce niveau le poète sur le
combat on n'est jamais sûr sinon c'est
trop facile le sport la compétition
on n'est jamais sûr mais il le faut que
cc c'est inconcevable que
qui passe à côté après être arrivé
jusque là c'est un petit peu leur
anglais que va voir et qu'on souvent les
boxeurs compte que c'est très très long
pourquoi après on leur propose la
possibilité de pouvoir obtenir un titre
mondial donc
donc si son année sur moment ou jamais
quoi il est 37e mondial actuellement
est-ce qu'il faut pas attendre qu'il
soit dans top 15 top 10 est peut-être
c'est une catégorie où il ya une
concurrence phénoménales
si la possibilité si on lui offre ce
combat là faut pas hésiter quand on met
tous les atouts de son côté pour pour
essayer de dial et et puis souvent se
voir ouvrir les les portes d'un
championnat du monde après qu'on soit
30e ou 20e sans combat tout cela sur un
combat oui mais à condition d'avoir eu
une préparation physique au top et un
mental aiguisé
donc je pense que tout est possible mais
il aura il aura parce que c'est un c'est
un bateau se sentent catégorie 1 soit
cette catégorie il ya beaucoup de monde
et où la préparation physique est
primordiale ce serait encore sur les
poids lourds et poids lours pas tout à
fait pareil et on pourrait on pourrait
dire il a peut-être encore un peu le
temps mais sur cette catégorie poids
welters il ya beaucoup de monde ça va
très vite et je crois que c'est son
année ou jamais stéphane faudra jouer
des poings si les prêts qu'ils y aillent
ça sera le mot de la fin sont
symptomatiques
si c'est maintenant à notre page coup de
projecteur on va parler de cyclisme dans
ce coup de projecteur une 78e édition du
paris-nice une nouvelle fois au départ
du 78 la course au soleil partira depuis
le département des yvelines pour la
onzième année consécutive lors de chaque
rendez vous les organisateurs doivent se
renouveler et créent de nouveaux tracés
objectif surprendre les spectateurs
on écoute le responsable du tracé
françois lemarchand depuis onze ans on
voit comme pas mal de choses les trois
dernières années encore davantage de
choses quand les conditions
atmosphériques climatique s'y met avec
du vent on voit on convoi des bordures
on voit tout un tas de tout un tas de
choses donc c'est ça le vélo aujourd'hui
donc il faut absolument qu'on trouve
nous organisateurs des terrains de jeux
et les yvelines nous offre la
possibilité donc de mettre en place ces
terrains cette année est la ville de
plaisir a été choisi comme terrain pour
accueillir la première étape de cette
édition 2020 le départ sera donné le
dimanche 8 mars depuis la commune le
peloton fera une boucle de 154 km à
travers les yvelines en passant par ben
montfort l'amaury ou encore
neauphle-le-château une satisfaction
pour plaisir qui a attendu de nombreuses
années avant d'être ville départ de
l'épreuve
ça nous ferons les chaque année mais
cette fois ci c'est vraiment bien
installé surtout que
le village va être dans le parc du
château qui est un lieu de rassemblement
familial est un lieu de rassemblement
festif pour l'ensemble de la ville
donc voilà on n'attendait que ça le
lendemain à ces chevreuse moins de 6000
habitants qui accueillera le départ de
la deuxième étape vers le loiret des
stars internationales comme julian
alaphilippe wigan bernal bas comme il
sera la 19e ville des yvelines à être
village départ de l'épreuve chevreuse
est considéré par les spécialistes comme
une terre de cyclisme
c'est vrai que c'est un endroit qui est
particulièrement prisée des amateurs de
vélo
beaucoup de professionnels aussi qui
viennent faire leur pré saison et leur
mise en route en ce moment d'ailleurs
sur les routes de la vallée de chevreuse
donc c'est un endroit qui s'y prêtent
vraiment où est que je pense les
cyclistes apprécié jean michel richefort
une réaction par rapport à ces deux
villes départ c'est une bonne chose donc
paris nice lens la saision
internationale en world tour avec les
plus grandes équipes au monde avec les
stars les stars du peloton et les
yvelines c'est un formidable terrain de
jeu
quand on quand on connaît la vallée de
chevreuse mais quand on connaît les mais
nul
on connaît également la cote 2,70 la
côte de neauphle-le-château et pour
cette première étape ce sera peut-être
un point décisif à 6 km de l'arrivée
mais cette première étape
généralement elle est réservée au
sprinter bien sûr tout le monde voilà
philippe mais les sprinteurs chez
cofidis y aura elia viviani
mais michael matthews n'est les
meilleurs sprinteurs mondiaux seront là
et je pense que la première étape ce
sera pour un sprinter et chevreuse la
capitale du cyclisme dans les villes on
peut le dire je rejoue la vallée de
chevreuse
on pense tout de suite à la vallée de
chevreuse et effectivement cheuvreux a
connu des écrans 2d grand passage avec
avec bordeaux paris avec le grand prix
des nations bien sûr c'est un terrain
terrain de jeu formidable et le départ
d'une étape la deuxième étape de
paris-nice qui partir de chevreuse pour
aller à châlette sur loing
c'est vraiment une très très bonne
nouvelle et un très bon choix de la part
d'aso l'organisateur de paris nice est
ce qu'après onze ans la relève quand
même à se renouveler oui parce que on
trouve toujours des dp des parcours des
parcours différents il y à des parcours
qui sont piégeux dans la dans la bd
chevreuse et puis surtout les conditions
atmosphériques on peut avoir du vent on
peut avoir de la pluie des bordures
comme l'a expliqué le directeur de
course
françois lemarchand et donc tout peut
arriver à vélo c'est la magie de ce
sport là on part mais bon
rien n'est jamais acquis et c'est bon
voilà encore une fois les yvelines
c'est un vraiment le département par
excellence du vélo une terre de vélo
c'est le coeur de jean michel richefort
un qui parle pierre chevallier est ce
que votre coeur parle aussi du succès
parce que je ne fais pas de vélo surtout
pas surtout pas accabler j'ai plein
plein plein de dénis qui font qu'ils
roulent qui roule et tous sont
dithyrambiques sur la sur la vallée de
chevreuse et sur les yvelines donc il y
avait ils viennent tous dans ce coin là
ils connaissent tous par coeur a priori
c'est effectivement là que ça se passe
c'est c1 c'est une terre de vélo on en
parle suffisamment sur ce sur ce plateau
et et ses choix de des deux villes
chevreuse était vraiment au coeur de
cette vallée dont les cyclistes sont
fans et plaisir bien c'est justement un
grand plaisir pour cette pour cette
merde d'accueillir ce bel événement et
quoi de plus beau que c'est que ce
département royal pour accueillir la
petite reine magnifique on gardera pour
le best-of de fonctions after chevallier
est ce qu'après onze on arrive quand
même à se renouveler
jean soler
on va se renouveler après 11 11 ans mais
moi ce que je dis moi ce que je peux
dire quand même c'est que maintenant les
grandes courses cyclistes ne peuvent se
passer des yvelines
c'est tout ce soit paris nice le tour de
france on a maintenant la possibilité se
renouveler bien sûr puisqu'on ne reste
pas sur le même parcours jamie celle là
dit il ya des plusieurs endroits dans
les yvelines l avantage c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs à mon avis que c'est que ces
s'est choisie parce que
professionnellement au niveau des tracés
on parle souvent la vallée de chevreuse
l'aller 12 virages 10 et ce tournant et
retournant voilà j'étais pas loin
c'est ça je t'ai parlé
voilà donc on parle souvent de ça mais
voilà il ya d'autres endroits de la cité
moi je suis pas spécialiste mais il les
a cités
donc il y a c'est vraiment je veux le
dire
soit le troisième à le dire la terre du
vélo et 12 les yvelines c'est dans la
terre du vélo et on ne peut que les
filles ne peuvent que ce ce la question
si vous voulez faire renouveler
voilà ils peuvent que se renouveler
aussi il ya tellement de possibilités
tellement de marco que ayant la botte le
buzet encore faut leur dire bon moment
leur dire que c'est pas finir alors en
tout cas l'histoire d'amour entre les
mines et de paris nice n'est pas près de
s'arrêter le partenariat qui devait
s'achever en 2020 devrait être reconduit
sauf retournement de situation cette
année pour quatre nouvelles éditions
supplémentaires
en parallèle le département va également
accueillir le tour de france cette année
au minimum et au minimum jusqu'en 2023
après avoir signé une convention avec le
département la question sur ce thème le
paris-nice doit-il disparaître au profit
du tour de france oui ou non
est-ce que c'est complémentaire ou
est-ce que le tour de france doit alors
remplacé le paris nice ça fait 11 ans
non d'accord moi je les y ai je dit
c'est parce que je reprends ce que jean
michel a dit il le disait avec tellement
coeur et ça peut les battre et 6 non non
pas du tout mais le parisis cela cela
tournait la saison internationale du
cyclisme
il l'a dit très bien et on peut pas se
passer ça le paris-saint plus et c'est
ancré dans le jeu parce que c'est la
course
après il n'y a pas et roubaix il ya
paris roubaix qui
après le tour de france bien sûr de tous
les fans je sais que c'est l'étape reine
mais la seule étape la compétition reine
à pardon mais mais c'est que paris-nice
paris-roubaix c'est incontournable
c'est vraiment incontournable donc
surtout pas sur nous mais ça surtout
quand on voit un peu ce qu'on est
capable de faire les yvelines faudra pas
leur donner du pouvoir par contre pas
trop la marque wassila ses fans amis se
laisser habiter le jus de poire oui
stéphane / le jus de poire je suis
d'accord avec jean parce que j'ai
toujours aussi peur et puis non c'est
bien parce que j'avais été je crois que
c'est quand j'étais par terre pour vous
les deux courses paris à paris nice et
lille peut pas enlever le paris-nice moi
j'avais et je crois il était parti de
maurepas une fois les parties de
maurepas effet teamorigin et c'est très
bien pour les versions c'était en 2015
ou 2016 malawi pour pour les villes qui
accueillent le départ c'est phénoménal
c'est ça fait venir du monde ça fait
connaître l'endroit puis les yvelines
c'est c'est les yvelines il ya le
potentiel culture potentiel public
potentiel pratiquants en france autour
du vélo donc il ya de la place pour
toutes ces grandes courses là
la seule chose qu'il faut qu'on qu'il
faut considérer c'est qu'à priori toutes
les grandes courses partout arrive à
paris on a cité le paris-roubaix paris
nice il y avait paris-tours aussi qu'il
existe mais c'est donc c'est peut-être
ce côté centrale de l'île de france qui
peut qui peut peut-être froisser
certains spectateurs aux aficionados
mais en fait un rôle
après par le tour de france notamment où
le paris nice les caravanes et les
pelotons viennent à la rencontre de tous
les français de toutes les provinces
donc il ya il ya largement la place pour
plusieurs grandes courses dans l'année
pour trois étapes
il ya la place trois étapes dans des
villes étapes 1 résume bien sur wii ou
adil et les dépôts les possibilités sont
quasiment presque sans limites vu la
bulle et la beauté là et la topographie
aussi dérouté civile normalisation est
ce que c'est le même public je me
chargeais choix sur le tour de france le
paris nice oui c'est un public pas de
peut-être un peu plus experts sur
paris-nice sur paris nice
oui il n'ya pas la caisse de résonance
médiatique du tour de france sont plus
d'aider des spécialistes qui vont voir
paris nice et c'est moins médiatisé mais
c'est une bonne chose que le tour de
france partait également pour cette
dernière étape
et cette année demandent davantage et
mantes-la-jolie 9 juillet prochain à la
halle berry en juillet il faut savoir
que le tour de france a été avancé d'une
semaine du fait des jeux olympiques donc
vise 9 19 juillet mantes la jolie paris
avec un très beau tracé dans les
yvelines
et puis cette dernière étape c'est la
consécration
on fait un peu
la fête dont le maillot jaune ça y est
il est fixé il ya plus de il ya plus de
surprises et on va jusqu'aux champs
elysées ça fait de superbes images
et puis cette dernière étape est suivi
dans le monde entier
160 pays retransmettent le tour de
france et 1 6 million de personnes cette
année ont regardé la dernière étape du
tour de vous c'est incroyable c'est un
coup de projecteur paris et ses environs
font 5 millions de personnes par étapes
non mais ccc suivi c'est un coup de
projecteur fantastique et moi je pense
que c'est une bonne chose est que le
département le conseil départemental
fasse la promotion du vélo dans les
yvelines qui est un sport populaire
voilà sans pour autant
donc faire de l'ombre aux autres sports
mais bon voilà on ne peut être que
d'accord le paris-nice passera donc par
les yvelines des 8 et 9 mars prochains
coup de projecteur maintenant sur les as
portis 20 sur dans les yvelines
en 2020 il y en a bien sûr des dizaines
à suivre mais nous en avons sélectionné
on commence tout de suite par victor
webb anyama originaire à des yvelines le
basketteur qui joue actuellement à
nanterre mesure deux mètres 18 à 15 ans
et mesure 2 31 m d'envergure et il n'a
pas atteint sa taille définitive
il a débuté au chesnay versailles là un
profil qui lui permet d'être sur place
et depuis ses débuts il a participé à
l'euro avec les bleus et les a emmenés
jusqu'en finale
ses statistiques lors de ce tournoi 9
points et 9 rebonds et 5 points 3
contres
il a également fait ses débuts en pro
contre brescia en eurocup
il a joué à 32 secondes mais il a joué
une réaction sur ce joueur autour de
cette table
stéphane devise est je crois que vous le
connaissez bien oui enfin lui non mais
je connais un peu sa famille je sais
qu'il aime comme vous avez dit qu'il a
été qualifiée en u18 en espoirs et en
pro qui va faire la coupe de france u17
il fait de mettre 18 il va il va avoir
16 ans et puis il a un avantage
contrairement aux autres grands du
basket c'est que lui il joue peu
intérieur intérieur raquette c'est à
dire pour récupérer les balles et y lire
sortir
il a cette capacité de fusil à trois
points
c'est une corde en plus à son arc que
peu de basketteurs de cette taille ont
ensuite bas il va perdre l'euroligue
junior à kaunas du 7 au 9 février et une
info il a été invité en 2019 au all star
game heureux junior
juniors la all star game il va faire le
all star game donc un joueur suivre
c'est un joueur qui est déjà suivi par
des clubs de proies par la dé barcelone
aussi et puis des clubs de nba qui
commence petit à petit à arriver et à
mettre une petite pression à son
entourage pour qu'il puisse quand il
sera en âge d drafté de d'aller aux
états unis.vers chevalier je suis d'où
je suis épaté ma part c'est par ces
jeunes générations lcc champions qui
école qu'on le voit éclore c'est
fantastique pour le patrimoine
patrimoine sportif français
ça me rappelle un petit peu les débuts
du fils noah avec un peu le gab a le
gabarit mais là là là ça semble assez
hors norme
surtout s'ils jouent pas pivot
effectivement à deux mètres devait 18
sachant qu'il a pas a priori
complètement fini sa croissance
l'envergure l'agilité l'agilité qui
lasse et c'est fantastique de compter
dans l'est dans les rangs français là
des équipes de jeunes un tel ou tel
joyau une telle pépite qui va qui va
exploser à priori à l'échelle européenne
d'abord française puis européenne et
puis peut-être si on lit ici on lui
prédit un bel avenir une draft nba et
des ide allait justement se frotter aux
meilleurs du monde
est-ce qu'il faut patienter encore un
petit peu avec ce joueur jean ou est-ce
que dès 2020 il faut le mettre sur le
devant de des projecteurs on a vu alors
quand il est jeune il est jeune il
faudra peut-être pas mettre trop trop
les projecteurs sur lui et le laisser le
laisser entre guillemets dans tous les
sens du terme grandir un peu tout seul
parce que c'est là mon avis un grand
virage à à passer d'un et il faudrait
pas aller trop trop vite parce que ces
jeunes qui jouaient les mensurations a
même pas 16 ans et pas trop laisser
grandir du coup mais il a si la pas fini
jusqu'où peut-il aller ce garçon mais je
crois que ça va être assez fragile est
coincé à la fois impressionnant mais
c'est fragile je crois que derrière il
ya ce alors qu'il soit très bien entouré
très intelligemment entouré parce que
forcément il va être convoité il l'est
déjà
il entre aux intentions il suffit de
citer à kaunas à zune est une assemblée
mais c'est vraiment elle son bateau n'a
pas droit c'est une ville c'est une
ville oui je sais je sais je connais le
col et kaunas d'ailleurs et donc c'est
vrai qu'ils convoitent et convives à
l'être il va falloir qu'il soit bien
entouré la tête froide qui se concentre
à ce qui s'est fait et ce qu'il sait
faire de bien et quand même ce ne sera
pas évident ce sera pas évident parce
que c'est quand même phénomène il faut
le reconnaître c'est un phénomène
jean michel richefort y en avait connu
des pépites pas forcément basket mois
dans le cyclisme et wii fit toujours
impressionné par deux jeunes prodiges
comme ça qu'ils savent tout faire lui
moi j'ai eu la chance de le voir jouer
deux fois
effectivement c'était impressionnant
impression le terrain c'est
impressionnant et puis une maîtrise déjà
une maîtrise du jeu et tout mais il a la
jeunesse pour lui mais après
effectivement comme très bien dit il
aurait très complet il peut marquer il
peut défendre
il est complet mais comme l'a dit fort
justement
jean après voilà faut laisser mûrir
doucement parce qu'avec les
sollicitations et sert à un moment donné
on peut péter les plombs facilement de
s'est déjà vu dans d'autres sports pour
deux jeunes prodiges comme ça mais voilà
une
il est au pied d'une grande grande
carrière internationale je pense et
c'est ce qu'on peut lui souhaiter
et également peut-être pour emmener
l'équipe de france également sur des
grandes échéances dans les années à
venir échéant championnats du monde et
les jeux olympiques
si ça continue je pense que c'est la
future grande star de l'équipe de france
si ça continue comme ça je mise gros sur
lui et une petite info c'est qu'il a un
entourage qui le protège très très très
bien ils ont la tête sur les épaules
ils ont coupé ils ont coupé tout ce qui
peut venir de l'extérieur qui peut lui
être néfaste et je peux te dire avec
certitude que l'année prochaine il
continue à nanterre pour justement lui
permettre de grandir en première
formation stéphane devise est je vais je
prends sur moi
mais ces deux sources vraiment très sûr
et il sera à nanterre l'année prochaine
l'avantagé du groupe au service et
surtout donc la nuit prochaine il sera
l'année prochaine il sera aux lakers de
los angeles et puisque je m'avance
surtout pourquoi poche et c'est toujours
la trouille de gens qui me fait dire des
bêtises corse alors autre espoir à
suivre même si on la connaît depuis un
petit moment matt hill de gros la
pistarde de 20 ans qui s'entraîne au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines bat tous les
records de précocité les notamment
double championne d'europe du keirin et
elle sera l'une des têtes d'affiché de
la délégation française aux jo de tokyo
cette année est ce que c'est une vraie
pépite à suivre jean michel richefort ou
qui la connaissent et bien oui matt hill
2 bien sûr que c'est une pépite
c'est aussi l'arbre qui cache la forêt
dans le cyclisme féminin il faut le dire
et au niveau de la fédération comme au
niveau du sport cycliste français mais
tous les espoirs féminins repose sur
mathilde et notamment pour les prochains
championnats du monde et bien sûr
l'échéance suprême
les jeux olympiques au mois d'août alors
elle peut ramener médailles dans ses
bagages oui bien sûr bien sûr peu mais à
condition d'être au top de ne pas lui
mettre trop la pression parce qu'elle
est jeune encore aller elle est très
jeune pas trop de pression
elle en a toutes les qualités physiques
mentales
et puis avec une marge de progression
c'est ce qui est encore souligné chez
mathilde les pins au sommet de ce soir
là encore une marge de progression
faux souvenirs que les très jeunes dans
le vélo elle a été détectée à l'été
basketteuses et elle a été détectée sur
des sur des tests sur des tests
physiques
elle est venue les venues donc au vélo
et tout de suite elle s'est affirmée
effectivement la marge de progression
devant des est bon et si elle n'est pas
championne olympique à tokyo
je pense qu'elle a de grandes chances
pour le devenir à paris en 2024
mais c'est sûr que là aujourd'hui c'est
la numéro 1 au niveau féminin sur la
piste je ne sais pas si vous vous
souvenez de matic de gros à l'art gros
caractères elle est partie notamment au
japon
je vous trouve sa préparation pour
s'entraîner pour le keirin
non je crois que jamie chaleur de
caractère de caractère d'aller au
chapeau à s'entraîner mais
serait qu on la suit on la suit dans
cette émission depuis un moment et on
sait on sait quelles séquelles que c'est
ce qu'elle veut quoi ça c'est évident
elle a les qualités énormes on serait
pas que le jeune basketteur finissent au
vélo trouvé le nom mais sinon sinon bien
sûr
moi je le dis je dédie d'ailleurs on
peut ressortir les bonnes je les dis
quel échec alors une médaille
quelles qualités qu'elle met d'ailleurs
je les dis je leur maintien et vidéos à
vous pouvez sans que la vidéo moi je
suis grosse de fans
j'affirme ce qu'il faut moi je la vois
médaille d'argent alors une autre
rapidement pierre chevalier si c'est pas
une preuve de caractère d'aller
s'entraîner au japon c'est au moins une
preuve d'ouverture d'esprit et de
détermination et d'aller se frotter aux
meilleurs ça servira un moment ou un
autre
souhaitons que ce soit dès 2020 mais
sinon ça fera reculer pour mieux sauter
avec paris 2024 une autre pépite un
cyclisme sur piste sébastien à vigier
d'origine estonienne il s'entraîne
également au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines
il a 22 ans il a déjà remporté l'argent
en vitesse par équipes aux championnats
du monde en 2019 et le bronze les deux
années précédentes il a remporté le
bronze en 2018 en vitesse individuelle
il devrait également faire les jeux
olympiques cette année est ce que c'est
un grand espoir jean michel faure lui
aussi ah oui mais il faut que mathilde
euros sébastien voilà c'est la
détermination il a un caractère
incroyable il ne lâche rien et il sait
ce qu'il veut et il continue à
progresser moi j'ai connu sébastien à
kazan en cadets et en cadets déjà il
voulait atteindre le
le plus haut niveau il a franchi les
marges donc au niveau national au niveau
international et aujourd'hui devant lui
maintenant c'est les championnats du
monde et les jo de tokyo bien sûr il
sera sélectionné
je pense en vitesse individuelle
[Musique]
vraisemblablement en vitesse
par équipes et dont une grande chance de
médaille mais la concurrence est rude
aujourd'hui il ya une concurrence
mondiale avec des anglo saxons avec les
néerlandais et ce sera quand même
difficile très difficile d'aller
chercher une médaille aux jeux
olympiques mais en vitesse individuelle
en vitesse par équipes mais il faut y
croire j'y crois sera plus dur que pour
masquer d'euros pour sébastien ce sera
sûrement un peu plus difficile même s'il
ya une grosse concurrence également chez
les femmes
mais chez sébastien oui et sébastien moi
je le verrais plutôt san apogée en 2024
encore il a une marge de progression
mais il sera là parce que il a un mental
incroyable c'est le gars qui était
indestructible lâche rien il y aura
également une triathlète suivre dans les
yvelines à cassandre beaugrand la
sportive de 22 ans également licencié à
poissy a déjà été championne de france
courte distance est également championne
de france d'europe et du monde en relais
mixte avec l'équipe de france de
triathlon
elle a déjà participé aux jo de rio à la
était 8e au classement mondial en 2019
et sera sûrement aux jo de tokyo cette
année est ce que c'est une belle
promesse qui la connaît autour de cette
table jean michel jarre michel a
beaucoup bossé je la connais oui je suis
le triathlon bien sûr il ya du vélo et
cassandra émis une classe une classe
phénoménale et le progress bon
maintenant
le voit sur les grands prix elle
rivalise avec les meilleures mondiales
et c'est une réelle chance pour tokyo
est d'ailleurs l'équipe de france de
triathlon a progressé ces dernières
années et même chez les garçons
également il ya des chances avec vincent
luis mais cassandre moi j'y crois
sur une sur une discipline aussi
exigeante que le triathlon il faut on le
sait des capacités physiques
particulières et complémentaires si tu
la connais sur la partie sur la partie
vélo et que et qu'elle a déjà sept 7
cette faculté là à boucler des tours
rapidement c'est un gage de ses
engagements de de potentiel du moins est
peut-être que le triathlon féminin et
est aussi une discipline qui est plus
ouverte que chez les hommes est donc une
une chance de médaille et une chance de
palmarès pour une jeune femme comme
celle là on va terminer à part un pilote
automobile hadji milhas le gluant
courtois a été à sept ans et 10 mois le
plus jeune champion de l'histoire du
sport automobile sur mini kart et
aujourd'hui chez tony kart il vient de
resigner à 11 ans il continue à
enchaîner les bonnes performances avec
son équipe et fait partie des pilotes
les plus suivies en europe et
participera cette année au championnat
et mini 60 géré par la fda qui
regroupera les meilleurs mondiaux
il va notamment faire des courses en
italie l'ajustement genlis vous qui le
connaissez bien qu'est ce que vous en
pensez de j mis à jour est d'accord on
avait fait un reportage sur lui
on avait dit que bon ça c'était bien
mais que c'était c'était très jeune il
fallait attendre un petit peu mais là on
il grandit grandit confiant et continue
à confirmer des grandes écuries commence
à lui faire des propositions
le conserve le fonds le fonds aussi nié
il s'est un petit peu c'est encore pire
même que notre petit jeune basketteur
attention car attention il faut bien
continuer le laisser évoluer laisser
grandir un peu aussi lui tout seul
surtout dans un milieu encore plus plus
plus plus exigeants quel hacker de
leusse porto où il est montré ici sur
votre plateau lorrain journal des sports
ce qui m'avait surpris c'est sont au
delà de au delà son jeune âge évidemment
c'est son côté flegme et absence de
prise de tête total qui va bien à son
âge
d'ailleurs et 7 cette lampe
détermination qu'on pouvait qu'on
pouvait qu'on pouvait détecter chez lui
une espèce de deux diamants bruts et de
talent de talent sur le pilotage
alors effectivement il faut lui laisser
le temps de
de grandir et d'arriver à maturité mais
montrait déjà une assurance au moins
dans son bac est assez étonnante
la question sur ce thème qui sera la
révélation de cette année 2020 selon
vous on va faire un petit tour de table
stéphane de bizet pour vous me victor
victor oui je pense qu'il va aller loin
il va faire une grande année ça j'en
suis sûr genre mathilde gros match de
gros serveurs sur l'addition du
potentiel et du du phénomène j'irai
victor victor pour blue jean michel le
coup de coeur pour mathilde de gros vous
êtes obligés de voter si tu lis alors à
passer maintenant notre page des bas
[Musique]
dans cette page débats je vous propose
de parler de course à pied le
département va accueillir une nouvelle
fois au mois de mars une course qui fait
de plus en plus parler d'elle la
diagonale des yvelines un trail qui
propose une traversée du nord au sud du
78 5 épreuves sont au programme
le 28 mars prochain et des distances de
12 17 44 et 84 km pour les plus
courageux
est-ce qu'il faut beaucoup s'entraîner
pour participants l'écoutent les
organisateurs ils étaient invités du 7-8
sport est-ce qu'il faut s'entraîner dès
maintenant pour ce qu'il est rentré
ouais ouais faut pas hésiter faut mettre
le paquet ceux qui vont qui vont partir
sur le 185
il faut y aller il faut y aller faut pas
hésiter c'est un travail de fond donc
si on voit arriver dans de bonnes
conditions avant les barrières horaires
avant la nuit dans les yvelines la
diagonale ne sera pas la seule course
organisée en 2020 cette année 91 courses
à pied outre elles seront organisées
dans le département
cette année il y aura notamment le paris
versailles qui devrait attirer près de
25 mille coureurs l'eco trail de paris
qui propose une course entre les
yvelines et la tour eiffel ou encore la
corrida pédestre international de
houille en fin d'année la question est
simple
est ce qu'il y a trop de courses dans
les yvelines vous votez oui ou non
oui pour jean-michel enfin petit ul
entre argent et jean-michel recommencer
avec plaisir
y'a jamais ces deux courses à jamais à
cette compétition et on le dit on le
répète souvent que ce plateau on a la
chance d'avoir un département qui est
riche en organisation sportive quelle
qu'elle soit et notamment au niveau des
courses et en plus il ya l'environnement
qui s'y prête avec de nombreuses de
nombreuses forêts de des parcours
magnifiques pour toutes ces catégories
de discipline qui sont organisées il y
en a jamais assez jamais assez ça ça
fait vivre le côté sportif du
département ça amène s'amène semaine du
monde ça le sport c'est la saleté qu'on
peut qu'être fier et encourager ce genre
d'initiative jean michel durand la
pression je suis un peu plus réservé bon
jeu reconnaît qu'actuellement le trail a
le vent en poupe et fort et
effectivement c'est formidable de de
courir dans le milieu naturel
mais quand même 91
manifestation de ce type il y en aura
plus en dépend ça fait beaucoup parce
qu'on banalise on banalise le sport les
organisations après on emprunte les
mêmes parcours on risque également
de dégrader certaines certaine portion
de parcours fragile notamment dans les
forêts moi j'ai connu ça il y a une
dizaine d'années avec avec le vtt où
tout le monde voulait faire du vtt tout
le monde voulait organiser des
randonnées vtt et après bon ça c'est un
peu canaliser je crois que là on est un
peu victime d'un phénomène de mode
et après ça devrait se stabiliser et
mais ça n'apporte rien c'est de vouloir
multiplier à souhait des événements bon
il faut des événements départementaux
régionaux de grands événements qu'il
soit médiatique est également mais tous
les dimanches dans tous les sens je
pense que ça peut être un élément qui
risque de nuire à terme à la discipline
pierre chevalier projet du siècle un
projet du siècle au même titre que les
cinq fruits et légumes par jour le sport
pour la santé c'est le phénomène où le
projet le projet du siècle la course à
pied à ceux à ce gros avantage de
pouvoir plaire à tout le monde de
pouvoir être facile à pratiquer la
preuve il ya même des gabarits comme le
mien qui s'alignent sur des sur des
marathons millions de français courau
mais c'est fois cinq semaines est
fantastique c'est fantastique et près de
5 millions de français participent
chaque année à une courtier exactement
on part de chez soi on rentre rentrer
chez soi ça peut prendre 10 min comme ça
peut prendre quatre heures ou plus pour
ceux qui partent pour les 80 bornes le
l'équipe moe le prix de l'équipement est
assez est assez modeste chose quand on
commence à s'enflammer et à s'équiper de
partout avec des mondes connectés autres
ça permet à aux uns et aux autres de
pratiquer une activité sportive
régulière d'aller ensuite découvrir ou
redécouvrir les fantastiques chemin
forest des yvelines il ya des traces et
des traces et partout il ya même tous
les tracés que les uns et les autres
inventent chaque chaque jour maintenant
et des applications connectées aussi qui
permettent
qui permettent d'aller d'aller explorer
et de se mesurer les uns et les autres à
distance c'est juste une compétition
permanente et donc à ce titre là il y
aura jamais trop de course officielle
puisqu'il ya aussi toutes les autres
officieuse qui permettent à tous de
faire du sport avant de passer la parole
à steve analyser rapidement que sur
quelques courses où seraient alignées
pour ton pc venir des transferts le
paris new york paris new york times
baraton new york a commencé les effets
des mises est convaincu j'apprécie
beaucoup et qui me fait toujours aussi
peur
non ce que j'aimerais dire c'est que les
yvelines c'est une belle région
c'est une région de sportifs aussi et
c'est très bien qu'ils aient plusieurs
courses pour permettre à des gens qui
ont plusieurs niveaux de faire la course
qui qu'il préfère j'espère d'ailleurs
qu'il ya du handisport dans ce court par
des courses voilà les joëlettes oui des
sportifs également partie c'est moi je
serais intéressé par faire l'un de ses
défis pourquoi pas ce sera intéressant
soit le 12 ou je ne sais plus il ya
pourquoi pas le paris new york également
le cuir chevaline voilà voilà
après un bon jus de poire moi je vous
fais le pari tout ce que vous voulez
peut-on se terminer comme d'habitude par
une citation aujourd'hui je vous propose
de terminer par une citation de l'ancien
boxeur mohammed ali
on ne devient pas champion dans un
gymnase en devient champion grâce à ce
qu'on ressent un désir un rêve une
vision je vous laisse méditer sur cette
phrase à bientôt sur tv à 78
[Musique]